top prosecutors from across the country
expected together in st. Louis today to
expose what they say are coordinated and
racist efforts to block criminal justice
reform they're supporting the city's
chief prosecutor who filed a landmark
federal lawsuit yesterday against her
own city and its main police union now
she claims she's being forced out the
union called the lawsuit the last act of
a desperate woman
Jeffrey gazes in st. Louis where he
spoke to chief prosecutor Kim Gardner in
an interview you'll see first on CBS
this morning
Jeff good morning to you good morning
Gardner is the first African American
circuit attorney here in the city of st.
Louis and she will be joined here today
by seven other black prosecutors black
female prosecutors from seven other
states who say they have experienced
similar attacks as they try to reform
police departments in their states this
is not about a single case or issue
facing the city of st. Louis prosecuted
this is the affair administration of
justice in the new lawsuit st. Louis
chief prosecutor Kim Gardner alleges her
civil rights were violated the thirty
two-page document cites the Ku Klux Klan
act rarely used law passed soon after
the Civil War it alleges the city and
its police union attempted to intimidate
silence and sideline her from bringing
criminal justice reform including an
independent team to investigate all
police involved shootings but the police
union is pushed back against that yes
they have the complaint alleges the
officers association had gone out of its
way to support white officers accused of
perpetrating acts of violence against
African American citizens it includes
the case of Michael Brown the teenager
who was black was shot and killed by
white police officer Darren Wilson
Wilson was never charged and later
resigned but the lawsuit says the police
union leader was outspoken in his
support for Wilson the fact that you're
filing this lawsuit is that not a sign
that you're losing this fight to reform
no it's a sign that we're not gonna lose
a fight to reform you think so it's a
sign that we're going to promote the
will of the people and we want to make
it where
other reform out of prosecutors who come
after us are able to go even further
than what we're able to do in her
complaint Gartner includes anonymous
threatening letters she says she
received last May after hiring an
outside investigator for a criminal case
against former governor Eric Greitens
Greitens was accused of computer
tampering and invasion of privacy all
charges were dropped but he resigned
public officials they get hate mail is
what you're receiving different you
think yes it is the lawsuit also
highlights a watchdog report that
identified more than 400 racist and
offensive post by current and former st.
Louis City police officers something we
reported on last year in a CBS News
investigation when we spoke to a 19 year
veteran of st. Louis City PD do you
think that there are white supremacists
on the police force yes I think so
you didn't even pause you know have you
seen some of the Facebook posts of some
of our suspended officers right now yes
we asked Gardiner about that I believe
that there are some individuals they
have race issues on the police
department but you need to ask the
police department what are they doing
about that in a statement the city of
st. Louis denied her allegations against
it and says it fully expects to be
vindicated in a court of law
this woman needs to go she's in a radio
interview last September local police
union leader Jeff Gordon said Gardner
should be removed by force by choice
what did you think when you heard that I
think that was a threat Roy was able to
speak unchecked without any
repercussions
and that's not okay in a statement worte
calls this lawsuit of frantic ploy to
deflect attention from an investigation
into Gardner's alleged mishandling of
the case against former governor
Brighton's you've become a lightning rod
have you ever thought about just
stepping away resigning I stand on the
shoulders of the people who paid the way
from me what if the other civil rights
leaders decided is too hard where would
be now it's about standing up for what's
right
Geof roorda was named in that lawsuit
but he declined our request for an
on-camera interview as for the private
investigator that Gardner hired in the
Greitens case he was indicted last June
on multiple perjury charges he denies
that he did anything wrong but the whole
case raises questions about Gardner's
conduct what did she know about his
alleged crime she denies doing anything
wrong
quite a story Jeff a lot of layers but
let me ask you this help us understand
why did Kim Gardner go to an outside
investigator to look into governor great
ins alleged misconduct the former
governor well and that is a really good
question because it speaks to the bad
blood and mistrust between the st. Louis
City PD and Gardner that's why she did
not trust the local police force to help
in that investigation and that's why she
went to this former FBI agent to help
her investigate the former governor
alright when you don't trust your own
Police Department or these and you're
the prosecutor thank you very much Jeff
you